>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jason Steinhauer: Good afternoon,
my name is Jason Steinhauer,
I'm a program specialist
at the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Today's lecture is presented
by the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant
scholar center on Capitol Hill
that brings together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to stimulate and energize one
another, to distill wisdom
from the library's rich
resources, and to interact
with policymakers and the public.
The center offers opportunities
for senior scholars,
postdoctoral fellows, and PhD
candidates to conduct research
in the Library of Congress
collections.
We also offer free public
lectures, conferences, symposia
and other programs and we
administer the Kluge prize
which recognizes lifetime
achievement in the study of humanity
and which we will award
later this month.
For more information about
these and other events,
as well as opportunities to
conduct your own research here
at the Library of Congress, please
visit our website LOC.gov/Kluge
or sign up for our RSS list
on the table on your way out.
Today's lecture is
titled Images of the Earth
in American Children's Books.
Our speaker is German
fellow, Sibylle Machat.
Machat's research focuses
on depiction of earth
in children's books from
1843 to the present.
Her research draws on several
collections held by the Library
of Congress, including those of
the Children's Literature Center,
the Rare Book Collections
and the Greshnikov Collection
of Soviet Era children's
books in the Business
and Science Reading Room.
Her study considers the collective
imagination of space prior
to photographic evidence
and through the imagery
in children's books clarifies the
relationship of modern humanity
to its planetary environment.
More about Sibylle's work
is currently on our blog,
it's right up there and she'll be
telling you more about her research
at the library during her talk.
Sibylle Machat is an associate
professor at the Europa University
of Flensburg and is
currently a German fellow
at the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Her first book was titled In
the Ruins of Civilizations,
Narrative Structures, World
Constructions and Physical Realities
in the post-apocalyptic novel.
At the Kluge Center she is working
on her second book on the depiction
of planet earth in American
children's and young adult fiction.
So please join me in
welcoming Sibylle Machat.
[ Applause ]
>> Sibylle Machat: All right,
let's see can you all
hear me okay like this?
All right, so we're going to
be looking at a lot of images
in this presentation
in the next 45 minutes.
So if you cannot see one
of the screens really well
now is your chance to move
to a place where you can see it.
It's more important to see the
screens than to see me even though
of course, it's nice
that you're all looking
at me and a little scary too.
To be honest.
So first of all, maybe
you've noticed these flyers
that have been lying around and
if you haven't seen one already,
please spend like 20
seconds thinking
about how you would describe
the planet earth to a child.
And just keep a couple of words in
the back of your brain and later
on I'm going to ask you to compare
whether or not any of these came
up during my talk like whether or
not you've maybe been influenced,
heard some of this before or
you came up with all new ideas.
Okay, so before we start and I
have a little Oscar speech to give.
That's sort of what we jokingly
call saying thank you to everyone
that you need to thank
up in the Kluge Center.
A couple of people said oh I
need to write my Oscar speech,
so I thought I would
put the Oscar in there.
So before we start I want to
thank the John W. Kluge Center
and Mary Lou Travis, Joann,
Lauren, Nancy, Jason and Dan,
and everyone else there who's
been so great and supportive
for what I've been doing here.
I also want to thank
my interns, Kira,
who's already in Japan doing
work there and Katie who's
in the audience and who has been
helping me with some scanning
and other slightly
boring things, thank you.
The Children's Literature Reading
Room and Sabella [assumed spelling]
who is also in the audience
has been very helpful.
The people in the Main Reading Room
who have been letting me use their
big scanner they all know me by name
by now and so do the
security guards.
I always go there with
my books and say hey,
I'm in the Kluge Center I want to
take these in and scan something
and take them out and by now
they just see me and they wave.
The Business and Science
Reading Room, which is the place
where you read the Russian
Children's Book Collection,
so I've been there.
The NASA HQ archives Liz, Colin and
Jane I spent two weeks there working
with their material, looking
for images of the earth,
early photographs to compare
them to the children's books.
And the Smithsonian and Space
Museum archives and Elizabeth there
where I also went looking
for early photographs.
And last but not least my home
university, the Europa University
of Flensburg who told me yes of
course, you can go for seven months
and not teach in the
summer term and do this.
Without them saying that
I would not be here.
Okay, so this is what
we're going to be doing.
The Earth in American
Children's Books.
We're going to start with a
very vague picture of the earth,
which you can see there on
the left next to the title
and the little astronaut and
the spaceship that's taking off.
And then we're going to follow the
path the spaceship is taking all the
way until we get to the blue
marble, so the first photograph
of the whole illuminated
globe of the earth --
well the half that you can see
if you're taking a
photograph taken by Apollo 17.
Okay, so this talk takes
place at a point in my project
where I have spent a long time with
primary resources, finding them,
building a timeline and a
database out of what I'm finding.
But I haven't yet done very
much work with secondary sources
or critical thinking really.
I did that when I first got
here I thought yeah okay,
I'm going to analyze all
these books in depth and look
at what I'm finding and
then really write it down.
So I did that for a month and then
I looked at all the things I wanted
to do and how fast
my time was going.
And then I changed my work
process a little and focused more
on the primary material itself.
So this is in the way.
So what I'm going to show you
in the next 40 minutes
is still very much a work
in process and all that it is.
I'm showing you what I found I'm
letting you look into my archives,
but I'm not claiming that my
thoughts have been finished.
If they ever can be finished at all.
So our journey is going to take us
through what triggered my project
in the first place, one of the
triggers and which I don't want
to tell you too much about
yet because it's going
to spoil the moment and then we're
going to spend five short minutes
on the theory behind
analyzing children's books
so you have a little context
for that before we're delving
right into the thick of it.
I'm going to be using three early
children's and young adult books
as the foundation for the pictures
of the earth that I'm going
to be showing you and the pictures
that I'm going to be constructing
for you, meaning that
we shall return
to these three books time and again.
And then we will also look at
how these things have changed
over the interim 175 years.
And these three books are going
to be Samuel Goodrich's
1831 Peter Parley's Tales
about the Sun, Moon and Stars.
J. L. Comstock's 1835
Youth's Book of Astronomy.
And John Blake's 1836 First
Book in Astronomy adapted
for the use in common schools.
Plus we're also going to
pre-empt the 1843 from the poster
by 12 years, but I found this
book and I thought this is great
and we're going to use this and
so starting 12 years earlier
than advertised I hope that's okay.
But first of all, this is what
really triggered my interest
in this project.
I'm going to be showing
you a two-minute video
and this is a compilation of the
audio recorded [inaudible] taken
on Apollo 8 overlaid with
the corresponding photographs
that the astronauts were taking at
the time the recording was made.
The setting is it's December
24th, 1868, 1968 sorry,
1968 we went to the moon 100 years
earlier, don't tell anyone 1968.
And Frank Borman, Jim Lovell
and Bill Enders have recently become
the first men to leave earth's orbit
and thus to see the
planet from a distance.
Granted orbit is also a distance,
but this is a greater distance.
And a little more recently
they've also become the first men
to see the dark side of the moon
with their own eyes
and to orbit the moon.
At this time, the time
that the video is set,
Apollo 8 has completed three
full orbits of the moon
and the three astronauts are
busy with their assigned tasks,
primary one which is to extensively
photograph the ground passing
beneath the spacecraft and to
visually appraise the approaches
to two possible landing sites on
the southern plains of [inaudible].
And then the following happens.
[ Inaudible Video Playing ]
Okay, I first listened to Apollo
8 recordings years and years ago
when I was writing my PhD on
an entirely different subject
and needed some tangential
information on the connections
between famous photographs
of the earth from space
and the environmental
movement for a talk
that I was giving an
interdisciplinary event.
And what struck me about the
recording was Bill Enders' choice
of words, he does not say look at
the earth or look at that or look
at that site no, what
he says is look
at this picture implying
something mediated,
something framed right,
a photograph, a picture.
It's not the earth itself he
says, look at this picture.
I might be over interpreting this
here, but it really struck me
and in a way it's of
course true 99.9999999.
And so [inaudible] percent
of the human population will
never see the earth from space
with their own eyes as a
whole, but it's something
that we always encounter
in a mediated fashion,
framed a certain way, labeled a
certain way, an image composed
and contextualized in a certain way.
And even if you're an astronaut one
might argue you cannot see the earth
directly, you need at least one
layer of glass between yourself
and the earth otherwise, you might
see it but it might be a painful and
or short lived experience right.
So it's always somehow mediated.
So yes, look at this picture and the
choice of words led me to thinking
about pictures of the earth and
about the fact that photographs
from space have now
existed for 69 years.
And thus at the time of the Apollo
8 flight had already existed
for an incredible 22 years.
So they've been around for a while,
but they're also a pretty
recent event in the course
of human history, even
if not entirely
as recent as they used to be.
If I look around here I think the
photographs have been around longer
than any of us here have been
alive right, so it's been a while.
Photographs of the earth from space
have been praised among other things
as raising human consciousness to a
new level of awareness of the earth
as a whole, of globality,
of the environment.
And while I certainly agree with the
statement, in my opinion thinking
of the earth as a planet is not
as recent a thing as some critics
and writers would make it out to be
and humankind has been
imagining the earth as a planet
for a much, much longer time.
So I went and became
interested in and began looking
for pre-space flight descriptions,
images of the planet
earth, and now here we are.
Over the last six months
I have according
to my bibliography software,
looked at a total of 1,011 items
from the Library of Congress, plus
about 50 Russian children's books
that I haven't been able
to add to my bibliography
yet because it doesn't deal
with [inaudible] very well.
Some of which were more
relevant some less and some
which I've spent more
time on and some
of which I actually still
have to look at in detail.
I came here with a list of books
that I knew that I wanted to see
and because I had some images
taken from them or read about them
in other bibliographies, but I
also tried to as systematically
as possible go through the
Library of Congress' digital
and card catalogs to look for
relevant books in my research area.
Images of the earth can be
found in connection to a number
of different fields of
interest, of course.
And the ones I spent most time
on are books that are concerned
with either astronomy, geography,
space exploration or spaceflight
in general, and all the
subcategories that fall into those.
About 70% of my primary
resources are fact books
for children whereas the other
30 are fictive space adventures
of some sort.
And though the lines often
blurred the most fact books
for children include an
imaginary part that's
like let's imagine we're
astronauts going to orbit,
going to the moon, going to Mars.
So there's fiction in
the fact books as well.
I've also tried to build as complete
a timeline as possible regarding
which early photographs
of the earth were taken
from various [inaudible] Aerobee,
Viking and Nike-Cajun rockets
and precisely when and then
released to the public precisely
when to compare and contrast
them with illustrations
and descriptions which I'm finding.
Which was the reason why I
went to the NASA archives,
why I went to the Air and Space
Museum, and also why I spent a lot
of time down in the newspaper
reading room looking at microfilm.
And Kira, my intern, also spent a
lot of time down there doing that.
So that being said about
the background of my project
and my research on to the
images of the planet earth
and children's book
theory before that.
In the book -- how picture
books work Maria Nikolajeva
and Carol Scott assert that and
I quote, the unique character
of picture books is based on
the combination of two levels
of communication, the
visual and the verbal.
They continue on by stating
that if we are making use
of semiotic terminology, we can
say that picture books communicate
by means of two separate
sets of signs,
the iconic and the conventional.
Iconic or representational signs
are those in which the signifier
and the signified are
related by common qualities.
That is where the sign is a direct
representation of the signified.
A picture of a printer on a
computer's command menu is an icon,
a direct representation
of the printer.
In most cases we do not
need special knowledge
to understand a simple icon.
Conventional signs have
no direct relationship
with the object signified.
The word print in a menu
only conveys the meaning
if you process the code, that is you
must know what letters stand for.
But letters together
to produce words
and understand what
the word stands for.
Conventional signs are based on
an agreement among the [inaudible]
of a particular language, both the
spoken language and communication,
such as gestures, dress
code and emblems.
For anyone outside the given
community conventional signs do not
carry any meaning or at best,
the meaning is ambivalent.
Thus, to understand the word
printer [inaudible] or I'm going
to mangle the Finish
kirjoitin, you need to be fluent
in the language in question.
Whereas, the icon that symbolizes
the printer transcends one specific
language and should hopefully allow
you to print things on computers
where the language is set to
one that you do not speak.
And if you've ever
accidentally changed the language
of your operating system into one
that you do not speak you notice
how long it takes to get back
to something you're familiar with.
So the printer hopefully should
work even if it's set to Chinese.
Both Nikolajeva and Scott
call conventional signs
and iconic signs have existed
in human culture for a long time
and have not only given rise to two
parallel types of communication,
visual and verbal, but also have
been frequently put into interaction
with each other in such multimedia
forms as say the theater, movies,
TV shows, video games, comic books
and of course also picture books.
Both the images and the words used
in picture books are complex signs.
The function of the words
are the conventional signs.
To stay with Nikolajeva
and Scott's terminology is
to narrate, to retell, to report.
Whereas, the images are there
to describe, to represent,
to illustrate, to visualize what
has been narrated to offer more
or less concrete representation
of the more
or less abstract concept
being narrated.
And picture books exists
somewhere between the two polls
of word and picture interaction.
On the one poll you find
text without pictures
and on the other poll you
find pictures without text.
So somewhere in between
you find the picture book.
Are there lots of pictures and very
little words or are there a lot
of words and very few pictures,
it's all a give-and-take.
And even there differentiations they
need to be made between narrative
and non-narrative interactions
of the two extremes.
So is it a story or
is it a dictionary.
Is it a picture narrative or
is it a picture dictionary,
like A is for apple
and B is for beer,
well probably not in
a children's book.
According to Nikolajeva and Scott,
images and text can interact
in a number of different ways from
being symmetrical where the pictures
and the text tell two mutually
redundant narratives all the way via
a number of steps to
selective picture books
where two narratives are told
independently of one another
and can, therefore, also
contradict each other.
The theory, however, concerns
itself with narrative picture books
that tell fictional stories
and does not focus so much
on nonfictional narrative books nor
did any other scholars that have
so far found focus on those books.
So most of these intricately
interwoven narratives
that Nikolajeva and Scott write
about are not actually
present in what I am finding.
In a large amount of the
books that I have been looking
at are what they kind of
lump together as plate books,
meaning nonfiction
illustrated books.
I will show you that
notwithstanding the lack
of theoretical in-depth
analysis so far.
Depending on the time these
books were published and the age
of the intended reader the variety
and the interplay between the text
and the illustration
nevertheless takes place.
One of my goals for my
own book project is also
to formulate a comprehensive theory
of the interaction between images
and text in nonfiction
narrative children's books based
on existing scholarly
work of course.
So that's one thing
we're looking at.
And the second thing that really
interested me in my project
and that I want to introduce
you to for like the next two
or three minutes is the interaction
between metaphors and similes
when talking about the planet
earth and children's books.
So earth is like a ball
or earth is a ball,
those are the two things
I'm finding.
So a simile earth is like a
ball is a figure of speech
that involves the comparison
of one thing to another thing
of a different kind used
to make a description
that is then more emphatic
or more vivid.
The metaphor earth is a ball is a
figure of speech in which a word
or phrase literally denoting one
kind of object or idea is used
in place of another to suggest a
likeness or an analogy between them.
While a simile compares two items,
a metaphor directly equates them.
In his book the Philosophy
of Frederick I.
A. Richards describes metaphors
as and this is another quotation,
the supreme agent by which disparate
and hitherto unconnected
things are brought together.
And he also calls metaphors a
transaction between contexts.
What a metaphor does
is not just to compare,
but to merge two distinct
contexts together.
As my talk is called images of the
Earth in American Children's Book
and not metaphors regarding
the Earth
in American Children's Books
we're going to be focusing more
on visual representations
rather than verbal ones
and the interplay between the two.
But in my final project I will
definitely be looking at both
and we're going to touch on
it a little bit here as well.
So while fantastic voyages
into space have a long tradition
reaching back to ancient Greece
and then continuing all the way
to the present from [inaudible]
of SAMOS' true history from 160
after Christ to Johannes [inaudible]
from 1634 and [inaudible]
a Voyage to the Moon
in 1657 to name but a few.
These are neither American books
nor are they purposefully written
for children and there
are no pictures
of the earth drawn in them either.
So they exist, but they do not fall
into my area of specific interest.
However, the earliest book I found
that is really of relevance is
from 1831 and was written
by Samuel Goodrich.
So Samuel Griswold Goodrich was born
in August 1793 and died in May 1860
and he was an American
bookseller and publisher and editor
and a writer and among the
first Americans who wrote
and published books for American
children and young adults.
Previous children's books had not
been written in the United States,
but instead been imported
from Britain and Europe
and for the most part, been
written by British authors.
Goodrich was responsible for
the publications of dozens
of works ranging from pocket-size
chapbooks to massive geographies
and according to the Boston
Globe sold 6 million copies
of his various books in total.
His most famous creation is
the character of Peter Parley
and we're going to look
at one of those books.
Peter Parley in the book
is a grouchy old man
who always tells children
that if they bump
into his foot he'll
stop telling them tales.
He's like a bit cantankerous and he
tells children tales about botany,
history, geography, astronomy,
and various other subjects.
Thus teaching the fictive children
in the books while entertaining them
and also the real children who
are reading them are being taught
and hopefully entertained
at the same time.
The book we're going to be looking
at is one of the Peter Parley tales
and as you can see here, its title
is Peter Parley Tales About the Sun,
Moon and Stars and it was
first published in 1831.
The edition we are going to be
looking at today is from 1836
and it is here in the
rare books collection
in the Library of Congress.
The book is fascinating
because it is an early example
of both some features that have
become common in children's books
as the decades progress and
because it also quite frankly,
contains some rather
strange illustrations.
And also an illustration
that points to a problem
that will hound children's books
illustrators for the next 125 years,
which we'll get to a little later.
But first let's see what
Goodrich actually has
to say about the earth in 1836.
So I'm going to read the text for
you, so just look at the picture.
This says chapter 4, Parley
tells about the earth.
On the following page is
a picture of the world.
I suppose you know that the world we
live upon is a vast globe or ball.
The [inaudible] side of which
is divided into land and water.
You know that it is covered
with seas and oceans and rivers
and mountains and valleys
and plains.
You know that the earth
is hung in the heavens
with stars all around it.
Goodrich continues on with facts
and numbers about the earth,
about the circumference and things
like that for the next two pages,
but interestingly quickly
[inaudible] the size of the earth
when he writes that how immensely
large then is the earth we
live upon.
When we come to the foot
of a mountain and look up
and behold it its magnitude
fills us with awe and wonder.
But the largest mountain is a mere
speck compared with a vast globe.
But as large as the world is
many of the stars which glimmer
in the heavens and appear
to us small are much larger.
A world when seen from these
stars does not appear bigger
than they do to us.
To the people who inhabit the
stars our earth is a star.
Look up at one of the stars in the
sky and imagine yourself upon it.
This world dwindled by
the distance would appear
to you a little glimmering
light so faint and far
as to be scarcely visible.
What is typical in Goodrich's
explanation of the motion
of the earth and the other
planets is that he tries
to explain the motion by
using everyday comparisons
that are easily graspable
by children and that will
for a large part remain unchanged
all the way to the present day.
When he talks I quote about
the motions of the planets,
I must now beg the particular
attention of my little reader
to what I'm going to say.
The seven planets of which I
have been telling you have each
of them two motions that is they
all turn round from west to east
in the same manner as the earth does
of which I told you
a little while ago.
They also move in vast
circles around the sun.
To make you understand this better
suppose you put a small stake
through the center of an apple
and call the stake its axis.
Now turn the apple around
on the stick, very well.
The apple turns around on its axis.
In a similar manner
each of the planets
and asteroids turns
round on its axis.
The earth turns around on its axis
every day or once in 24 hours.
Some of the planets turn around
in a shorter time than the earth
and some in a longer time.
Now suppose you take an apple and
tie a string to the stem of it
and whirl it above your head.
We will call the circle a
path in which the apple flies
about your head is orbit.
So if you whirl it swiftly the
apple will go around in its orbit
or go around you head
150 times in a minute.
And this is what you
can see here right,
there's the boy whirling
the apple around his head.
And this is what this
looks like later on.
Here's some more recent
illustrations
that show precisely the
same concept even if they
in more recent years
are usually applied
to explaining how satellites
stay in their orbits,
thus putting the child holding
the string in the position
of the earth rather than that of
the sun, which he or she inhabited
in Goodrich's explanation.
These illustrations are from Rose
Wyler and Gerald Ames' Golden Book
of Astronomy, a Child's Introduction
to the Wonders of Space illustrated
by John Paul Green from 1955.
And Maurice Allward's
Timothy's Space Book illustrated
by T. E. North from 1961.
And if you look at the slides
I always give you the names
of the authors, but
also of the illustrator
because I thought we're talking
about pictures and then I need
to tell you who actually
drew the pictures.
So this is the first one.
So Rose Wyler and Gerald Ames'
book the boy here is the sun
on the left-hand side
of the screen for you.
And the illustration
on the right here
where the earth is
actually moving is orbit
and precisely parallels the boy
whirling the stone around its head,
it's a stone here it's
no longer an apple.
And both of them explain
the combination
between centrifugal
forces and gravitation
which keeps the earth
orbiting the sun.
Maurice Allward's book was published
after satellites had been launched
into earth's orbit and thus explains
the interplay between centrifugal
and gravitational force
in term of the earth
and its satellites instead.
And the parallel is again made
explicit by the two drawings
on the right-hand side
displaying significant parallel
compositional aspects.
The location of the boy's had
parallel that of the earth right,
they're on the same place in
the picture and the conqueror.
This boy is not using an apple or
a stone, but he has a conqueror,
the conqueror is almost
in the same place
as the satellite is going
around in the orbit.
So again, you can see
the parallel compositions
between the two pictures.
So one parallel, but back
to Peter Parley for now.
The next illustration
show how Goodrich explains
that the earth turns around the sun
rather than the other way around
and that the sun always shines
on some part of the earth.
And so on the left you
can see someone reaching
out behind the curtain holding
an apple, so that's an apple
on a string that he's
holding next to the candle.
And the other one has the
sun shining on the earth.
So if you turn the
apple that you have
on the little string the
candle shines on its other side
and while your side might turn
dark the candle keeps shining
on the apple all the same.
This illustration also
introduces one of the problems
that children's book illustrators
often contended with and especially
in more recent -- no not so recent
book, where to put the clouds,
where do you put the clouds right.
When you look up at the sky you
see clouds, but when you look
at the earth from space do you see
clouds or do you not see the clouds?
And if we've talked about
my project at any length
in time I've probably joked to
you that before 1946 the weather
on the earth was much better
because there were never any clouds,
there are never any clouds
from space very rarely.
Interestingly, this
is not quite true
for this Peter Parley illustration.
Here the artist clearly knew that he
had to include the clouds somewhere,
but at the same time if you
don't want to obscure the view
of the earth and paint
them on the earth
and then the people can recognize
the earth where would you put them?
So here his solution was to put them
around the sun, which technically
from the point of view of
someone standing on the earth
and looking up is kind of true.
But also of course,
not actually the case,
so keep in mind where
the clouds are.
And last but not least, there's also
this interesting view of the earth
in the book, which really seems
to be planet water
rather than planet earth.
So we're going to zoom in a little.
The quality of my image
is not the best,
but you can see this is water world
more than it is anything else.
The book does not give
any explanation
for this it just has a ton
of ships on this planet
and no continents,
which is interesting.
And another interesting image
I'm going to show you is
from Samuel Goodrich's 1846
National Geography for schools,
so this is the front page.
And there again, we see
the clouds around the earth
and the earth looks like this.
Is there anything that
might be missing?
Asia yes, so the visible part
of the earth is only North
and South America, nothing else,
but he included the clouds.
So something of this and
a little less if that.
So now you've seen
Goodrich's problem of where
to locate the clouds and
also some images of the earth
without any clouds actually
between you and viewing it.
And let me show you how
the planet earth and clouds
on the earth's surface are depicted
in the intervening 180 years.
So these three, I hope you can
see these okay even from the back.
These are from John
Astor, yes the John Astor.
A Journey in Other Worlds and
Romans of the Future from 1894,
Mary Proctor's The Children's
Book of the Heavens from 1928
and the Stars for Sam
from W. M. Reed from 1931.
And here you can actually
see some clouds if you look
at the Astor picture,
which is the big one.
The description says the signal
is from the Arctic Circle.
So they need to find out
where they're going to land
and the signal helps them with that.
But you can actually see
South America and some clouds
around it whereas in the other two
books -- Proctor still has some,
but then in W. M. Reed's
book it's the first book
where we're starting
to lose the clouds.
So we have clouds and then we
start kind of losing more clouds
and we will not see
any clouds for a while.
So these are the next
illustrations -- that these are all,
these are from between
1935 and 1945 and that's
when we really start seeing lots of
books about space expiration again.
In the decades before that they
are few and far between either
in fiction or they're
astronomy books.
And it took me two weeks to figure
out why that is, why do people talk
about space a lot like
in the 1840's, 50's,
60's, 70's and then they stop.
It's because people start building
planes and all the [inaudible] books
of wonder are about aviation
and not about the stars anymore.
I felt very stupid once
I figured that out.
I thought of course, of course,
that's when we started having
aircraft and everyone's about hey,
we're going to fly the Pole
[inaudible] fly into space.
But space comes back.
So here as I said, these are from
W. B. White I'm Seeing Stars 1935,
Arthur Draper's Wonders
of the Heavens from 1940,
Bertha M. Parker the Earth's Nearest
neighbor, which is the big picture
and then the Picture Book of
Astronomy by Jerome S. Meyer,
which we will keep
coming back to today
which is the bottom left picture.
And here what is significant is
that the earth pretty much
look like a glow from space.
So there's an absence of the
clouds, we see very clearly North
and South America and inn American
children's books it's always North
and South America that you see.
In Russian children's books it's
not Russia interestingly enough,
they often show like in
the North Pole or parts
of Europe they don't focus to such
a degree on the US and South America
as American children's books do.
So now we're in 1945 there are
no clouds on the planet earth,
everything is sunny everywhere,
the weather is always good
and then silence has to
come in and ruin the view.
So it's 1946 and this happens.
This is the first photograph of
the earth in which you see clouds
from above and it was
taken on October 24th,
1946 and it's the first
photograph from space.
It was taken from a V2 rocket
launched in the New Mexico desert
and which had been fitted with a
35 millimeter motion picture camera
and went up to a suborbital altitude
of 105 kilometers or 65 miles
as I should probably say here.
The camera was destroyed
after being dropped back
to the earth, but the film survived.
You can see it here at the top left,
along with an image of the page
from the Christian Science Monitor,
which talks about it
which is on the right.
And here courtesy of the
Microphone Collection
in the Newspaper Reading Room.
I'm showing you this page
here alongside the photograph
so you can get a feeling
for the fact
that these images were
widely circulated
in the press, which
indeed they were.
And another highly influential
publication this time not a
photograph, but a magazine
article or rather a series
of magazine articles was
published in Colliers between 1952
and 1954 and that's this one.
And these are some of the
most influential drawings
of the planet earth
ever, ever, ever,
ever and especially
of space stations.
They inspired a great deal of
children's books' illustrators
and Colliers ran a series of
articles on humankind's future
in space in which leading scientists
talk about space exploration.
And these illustrations here were
taken from the first of these issues
of Colliers and this one was
called Man Will Conquer Space Soon.
The article is drawn by Chesley
Bonestell, one of the pioneers
of space art who greatly
helped popularize space travel
and whose illustrations have
become so iconic that people refer
to other artists as
either being Bonestallion
or not quite Bonestallion enough.
Here he is illustrating an article
written by [inaudible] Brown
about space stations and crossing
the last frontier into space.
And if you keep this picture in
mind and then look at the next one
so you can see what I mean about
them being very influential.
So especially the two on the right
they seem almost identical right,
it's a different artist but
clearly copies the style.
These are from Arthur C. Clarke's
Exploration of the Moon in 1954,
illustrated by Ralph
Smith and then Rose Wyler
and Gerald Ames' Golden Book of
Astronomy, a Child's Introduction
to the Wonders of Space, and Willy
Levy Man-Made Satellites Adventure
in Space from 1955 and 57.
And both of these were
illustrated by John Paul Green,
so that's why the images look
so similar it's the same artist
who clearly was influenced
by Chesley Bonestell.
The earth looks a bit scary here,
there's not a hole being dug
in the earth so the earth is not
slowly disintegrating into itself.
The book is illustrating
an eclipse of the moon what
that would look like from space.
So the moon's shadow
is on the earth here,
that's why it has that dark spot.
The next photograph that
is very influential or no,
the next autograph is from 1959
and shows the first photograph
of the earth taken from a satellite,
namely by the Explorer 6 Satellite
on the 14th of August
1959 from a height
of about 27,000 kilometers
or 70,000 miles.
The [inaudible], that's the one
on the top left it clearly
shows a sunlighted area
of the central Pacific Ocean
and its cloud cover right.
Of much better quality was the first
television picture from space sent
to earth on April 1st,
1960 and taken by TIROS-1,
the first successful lower
earth orbital weather satellite.
In the first of its years
of television infrared
observations satellites,
which is the picture
at the bottom left.
And it shows the coast of Maine
and Canada's Maritime Provinces
and this is when you really start
seeing the curvature of the earth
and to a greater degree and
cloud cover of the earth.
And you start actually using
and television pictures to talk
about the weather and suddenly
people know what clouds look
like from space to
a far greater degree
than they did before even there,
though there they already
know it for [inaudible].
And next then and this is what
really, really kicks it all off.
It's time for humans to get
in on the photography action.
Yuri Gagarin became the first
man in space on April 12,
1961 and in February 1962 John
Glenn, the third American in space
and took his camera along
with him and brought back,
among others the photograph
of the earth
that you see on the right-hand side.
And this is when you start having
pictures taken by humans from space
who then can talk about what
they saw, what it felt like to be
in space, and that adds an entirely
different dimension to the way
that people draw the earth and talk
about the earth in children's books.
And again, here are four
illustrations that sort
of parallel this cloud cover.
Some of them are more
realistic and some less,
but there's also some
time in between.
So the one where it's still very
sunny except for this tiny piece
of cloud out in the Pacific Ocean
close to Mexico is from 1958.
And then the one on the right
where the clouds are sort
of forming a little band around
the earth, I loved that image
when I saw it, that's from the
Sun, the Moon and Stars from 1959.
And then the bottom two ones are,
the bottom right one is from 1961
and the one on the
bottom left is from 1963.
And that one talks about
the first astronauts
in space while showing the
earth with a big cloud cover.
So again, in the bottom right you
can clearly see there are more
and more clouds being
drawn around the earth
as we have the photographs, so
I'm going to skip back here?
Look at the top right
photograph and then compare it
to the bottom right picture right.
So but maybe the most
influential single photo --
series of photographs for children's
books is actually of the spacewalk.
So the photograph on the top left
here shows Ed White's spacewalk
on the Gemini 4 mission
in June 1965.
And this is copied widely
in children's books.
So either they use the
photographs themselves,
as in the top right The World of
Rockets by Alexander [inaudible]
or in the bottom two pictures
where the photograph inspires art.
Before that the depiction
of astronauts is kind of all
over the place people don't quite
know what the spacesuits are going
to look like, they have huge
antennas sticking out of their head.
You're going to see one
of those pictures later.
But after this spacewalks look
like Ed White's spacewalk.
The next important images
from November 10th, 1967,
and offers the first full
view of the planet earth
that the public actually
gets to see.
There is most likely arguably
an earlier photograph taken
by a military dodge satellite which
was never released to the public.
And so while interesting it's
not interesting to my project
because it's never released it
cannot inspire anyone all right.
And like the photo that I will
talk about after this one,
this photograph has been largely
overshadowed in collective memory
since in its case by Apollo 17's
famous blue marble photograph.
So if I ask you what
was the first photograph
of the completely illuminated
glow from space,
most people would say
the blue marble.
And it wasn't actually
it was this one,
which was taken five years
earlier than the blue marble.
But when this photograph here was
taken it was a huge deal at the time
in children's books and it was
very quickly adapted into them.
So it was released, it caused
huge excitement for the public
and it was very quickly covered
and put into children's books.
So at the top right this
book is called Exploring
and Understanding our Solar System
by Daniel Q. Posin, it's from 1968.
So the year after and
I copied the image,
they've also reversed
it for some reason.
So everything is the
wrong way around,
but it's the first color photo
of earth taken from space
by the Aqueous 3 satellite.
And then in the books at the bottom
here they go chronologically,
actually and then all
over the place.
So the one with the [inaudible]
space stations from 1971 and then
at the far left it's 1977, bottom
79, and then 2008 at the right
which I show you here to see that
today it's mostly photographs
of the earth that are
used in children's books,
they don't do illustrations so
much anymore they use photographs
because we have so
many great photographs.
So photography wise it is 1967 now
and thus the year before Apollo
8 goes to the moon and that is
where we will leave
space photography for now
for the relationship between the
earth and the moon is something
that is also extensively covered
in children's books as well.
And for which we shall once
again start in the 1840's
and then move away forward.
All right, there are two more books
from the 1840's that I want to delve
into a little, namely J. L.
Comstock's Youth Book of Astronomy
from 1835 and John Blake's
First Book in Astronomy adapted
for the use of common
schools from 1936.
They're both interesting because
they while not providing the reader
with any detailed illustrations
of the earth itself,
discuss what the earth would
look like when seen from the moon
and thus highlight a very common
feature of children's books.
Someone is standing on the moon
and looking back at the earth
and when I say it's a very common
feature, I mean it's a very, very,
very, very common feature.
It's almost in every children's
books where you go into space,
you stand on the moon and
you look back on the earth
and you think something about the
earth and that changes over time.
So Blake -- so Blake in his
First Book on Astronomy adapted
for the use of common
schools writes the following,
as the moon illuminates the earth
by light reflected from the sun
so it is reciprocally
illuminated by the earth,
which reflects the sun's rays
to the surface of the moon.
And as the surface of the earth is
more than 13 times greater than that
of the moon, the earth
must appear to inhabitants
of the moon 13 times larger
than the moon does to us.
The rotation of the moon
and its axis being performed
in the same time that it goes
around the earth it is plain
that the inhabitants of one half of
the lunar world are totally deprived
of the side of the earth unless they
travel to the opposite hemisphere.
So if you live on the moon it
depends on where you live whether
or not you get to see the earth.
If you live on the far side
of the moon and then you go
around the earth you go oh,
what is this thing right.
And Comstock kind of
writes the same thing,
but he does so in a far
more lyrical fashion,
which is why I'm quoting it too.
We have already stated that one side
of the moon is never
turned towards the earth.
Consequently, to the lunarians which
are his inhabitants of the moon,
who live on the side nearest to
us the earth is always visible,
except when the moon
is in opposition.
But those who live on the opposite
side of the moon and always stay
at home never see the earth at all
because that side is
never turned towards us.
A lunar astronomer who happens to
live on the side directly opposite
to us would have to travel a quarter
of the circumference of his planet
to see the earth at all
that is about 1,500 miles.
And if you would see our orb
in its greatest magnificence he
must go 3,000 miles or to the middle
of the part next to us where
indeed he will behold a spectacle
which any terrestrial
astronomer would be happy
to enjoy at such an expense.
Namely a moon always directly
over his head, 13 times as large
as the full moon appears to
us and turning on its axis
so that he could examine
every part of it in 24 hours.
Don't you want to live
on the moon now?
So as I said, unfortunately no
detailed illustrations of the earth
from space or indeed
what the earth might look
like from the moon are provided
by either Blake or Comstock.
The most you get is in Comstock
this drawing of an eclipse
like when the moon is dark because
the earth is between the sun
and the moon, that's the
most you get of the earth.
And it takes almost a hundred years
until the first image of the earth
as seen from the moon shows up in
children's books and it is in 1924
in May Proctor's The Children's Book
of the Heavens and
it looks like this.
This is a typical image for the
1920's, so it takes a while to show
up and then these are the
kind of images you get.
And the best one in
color that I have found,
which is why I'm showing
it to you here.
The moon as we all
know from seeing it
at night shines bright
yellow in the earth's sky.
And so for a long time
it seemed to follow
that the earth too would be
bright yellow when we looked at it
from the moon right, one is
yellow the other one is yellow
seems logical.
This one is actually
slightly atypical
in that it does not show some
detail in the earth's surface,
even if the planet as a whole seems
more reminiscent of drawings of Mars
and the canals that
might exist on Mars
that were also frequent subjects
in children's astronomy
books of the time right.
If I said you what is this you'd
say oh is this Mars, it's the earth.
And the description says the earth
seen from the moon's [inaudible].
So details start showing up in the
1930's and these three images are
from left to right from Elena Fontay
of the world's [inaudible]
from 1930.
Otto Gail's By Rocket to the Moon,
the story of Hans Hardt's
Miraculous flight from 1931.
And W. M. Reed's The Stars
for Sam in 1931 as well.
So interestingly, the continents
here are only vaguely determinable
and clouds too seem
to actually exist
and obscure the features
of the earth.
So again, it's a parallel
to the earlier pictures
we had of the earth.
In the 1930's you have clouds, in
the 1940's there are no clouds.
And maybe unsurprisingly if you
look at the earth from the moon
in the 1940's there are no clouds.
So we're going back to Bertha M.
Parker The Earth's Nearest Neighbor
and then Jeremy S. Meyers,
the Picture Book of Astronomy
and on the far right Marion
Cothren's 1946 This is the Moon,
which sort of has the earth
rising behind the moon.
And this way of drawing the
earth doesn't really change
until the late 1950's and clouds
start appearing in these drawings
of the earth as seen from the moon.
So it really takes us after the
first satellites are in space,
but before manned spaceflight begins
for these pictures of the earth
to change a little as they
are seen from the moon.
And then you get pictures
like these and all four
of these are primarily concerned
with our future in space
and exploring the moon so you
can see various iterations
of rocket ships going
there or unmanned probes
that might land on the moon.
And you also always
see the earth somewhere
in the lunar sky, that's
very common.
If you draw people landing on
the moon and working on the moon
and you always include the earth
somewhere to show that they are
on the moon and not
on some random plant
and because it's a
nice visual sight.
So where am I, I adlibbed.
Photographs of the earth as seen
from lunar orbit are something
that once they are available
are also quickly integrated
into children's books as well,
somewhat unsurprisingly probably.
Maybe even more so by sheer
amount than the early photographs
of the earth from orbit
actually are,
which often only inspired art itself
rather than being copied one-on-one.
The first photograph of the earth
from lunar orbit, which was taken
in 1966 by the lunar orbiter
this very quickly turns
up in front papers and end
papers of children's books,
as well as integrated
into the text itself.
Today again, few people might
recall that this image existed
as it has been overshadowed by the
Apollo 8 and Earthrise photograph,
which we saw earlier
but it did exist.
And interesting about this picture
is that while it is integrated
into the text sometimes it
also shows up in the front
and in the end papers, even if the
book doesn't really talk about it.
It's just there because it
exists and you want to show it
to the children, that's my theory.
It's like it doesn't really fit in
the text, maybe the text was written
if the book is published shortly
after, but do include this picture.
And of course, you can
show it in the full spread
which is very nice visually.
So these here are two books
from 1967, which are used
in the front paper and
then in David Dietz's Stars
and the Universe it's actually
in the text when they write
about the moon what the
moon might look like.
So they use pictures that were
taken on the surface of the moon
and then also one from orbit.
But there are two pictures that
I really would like to talk
about in more detail
right now rather
than showing you endless
repetitions of globe earth
and spikey moon terrain, they
always have spikey mountains.
And these are both from a book
that was written and illustrated
by Anthony Ravielli and which
is called the World is Round.
The World is Round spends
most of its time explaining
that the world is round even if you
can't see that the world is round.
So it says the earth is a ball and
the earth is a really big ball,
but imagine you're a tiny fly
sitting on this really big ball.
So to you it seems flat,
but if you're a child holding this
big ball it's nevertheless round
even though the fly can't see it.
So like 80% of this book is actually
about explaining why
the earth is a ball,
which here the title
already shows you.
And then it talks about the earth
as a planet and space exploration
and the space program a little.
And what is interesting about this
book is that the Library of Congress
in its general collection has
two editions of this book.
And they are identical to each
other except for two pages,
one two-page spread,
namely pages 46 and 47
and this is what they look like.
Does anyone want to hazard a
guess what might've happened
between the first and the
second edition of this book
or when they might
be from very roughly?
What has happened here?
The moon landing has
happened indeed.
The book on the left it's the
-- let's see if this works yeah,
it's the 1963 edition
of the book and the one
on the right is the 1970
edition of the book.
And so you see a couple
of interesting changes.
And if you look in the 1963 one,
so the one on the left the moon
still has the very spiky mountains
that everyone thought
the moon would have.
There is no atmosphere on
the moon, so there's no wind,
there's no water, so there's nothing
to corrode the mountains away hence
the mountains must be very spiky.
And the stars are very
clearly visible in the sky.
The moon lander looks somewhat
different people are climbing
out the top which leads you to the
question how do they possibly get
out of that thing to
the lunar surface
if they're climbing out the top.
And then the earth looks very
different from the moon right,
there are very few clouds,
it's very clearly --
the two out Americas are visible.
And then on the right the
moon landing has taken place,
so you have a realistic
depiction of the lunar lander
of what the gear you need to
wear and the moon looks like,
the stars aren't as visible
anymore and the earth is very,
very cloudy as it looks
like from the moon indeed.
And this book was both written and
illustrated by Anthony Ravielli,
so clearly he cared enough about
the inaccuracies of his book
that he said I'm going to draw a
new page 46, 47 and we're going
to include this in
the second edition.
And I brought both versions
of the book with me.
I brought some books with me you can
look at after the talk in the Q&A
if you and so you can
sort of compare and see
that indeed everything
else is the same.
What does the moon actually look
like, what does the earth look
like from the moon that you
can see in this picture.
So this is a photograph taken
by Eugene Cernan in Apollo 17
and it shows you what
the earth actually looks
like in the lunar sky.
It's kind of tiny and
unimpressive isn't it?
So it's is very hard to photograph.
If you've ever tried photographing
the moon you've had this problem
either you zoom in so you see
nothing else except the moon
or you take a picture and then
there's this tiny moon somewhere.
And the same is true of the earth.
So here you see the
boulder in the foreground
and then the half lit
earth in the sky.
In drawings in children's
books the earth is much bigger
and more impressive.
So you can see that in the Ravielli
book where he didn't change the size
of the earth he kept that pretty
much the same he just changed what
it looks like and you
can see it in these here.
And the top right book is one that
I actually think is a little creepy,
it's called The Happy Moon, it's
from 1972 and it's about the fact
that the moon is really,
really very happy
about having people land on it.
But to me it looks like you're kind
of stepping on the moon's face.
So I read that book and
I thought oh actually,
this moon makes me
a little creep out.
And then at the bottom right is just
one of my favorite illustrations
because it's such a nice
spread and it includes the text
and the imagery really well,
it shows you the lunar surface
and the astronauts and
the earth and the sky.
This is by Richard Whittingham
and Barbara Brooks' The
Earth and the Stars.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
tell you who drew the picture.
And the one on the left is from
1969, so it appeared late in 1969
after the moon landing it's called
We Came in Peace, The Story of Men
in Space and it's one of the
first picture books to deal
with the moon landing itself.
And ever since the moon landing
in these pictures appeared this
is what illustrations of the earth
from the moon have looked like.
The moon is flat, there
are no spiky mountains,
the spacecraft look Apollo
like, the earth is cloudy.
And due to time constraints
because I think I'm kind of getting
on with my time I see
Jason nodding in the back,
this is where we're going to
stop looking at earth from moons
and then start turn our
attention very briefly to images
that illustrate more abstract ideas.
And that does closely tie into the
analysis of the use of metaphors
and similes in children's books,
which I want to at least
introduce you to a little.
And this is also the point where
we get to the merry-go-round
that you may be saw on
the poster for my talk.
So the first thing I want to
talk about is actually more
about the solar system
than the earth itself
and this is how do you explain
gravitational forces to children.
Right, we have the one where the
earth flies around on that string,
but if you want to talk about the
solar system what you commonly
or what I commonly
find are tugs of war.
So tug-of-war is a way
of explaining to children
that all the planets
influence each other.
So the one on the left is from Elena
Fontay again we're coming to back
to her, Other Worlds
than This from 1930.
And the one on the right is
from Herbert Townsend's
A Wonderful Earth,
The Story of How it Became the
Great Round Earth it is today.
And so he actually in
the Townsend you see
on the right-hand side
you see the sun sort
of having a tug-of-war
with all the planets.
So all the planets against the sun
and the sun is probably
still going to win.
And then on the left, which is
the same as in Fontay except
that in Fontay you have
people pulling, it's like some
of the bigger planets or certainly
the sun have more influence
and the smaller ones have less, so
they're drawn as smaller people.
But it also depends on where
you are in the solar system.
So Fontay's description says the man
with the greatest pulling power is
not always the biggest nor always
the nearest.
So Uranus might have more
power on Neptune than the sun
because the sun is father away
her illustration seems to say.
And the second one
is merry-go-rounds,
so many merry-go-rounds.
So again, this is a way
of explaining the fact
that the earth turns around itself
and also rotates around the sun.
So in Jeremy Meyer's book,
which is also the poster
that I have you can see the
merry-go-round superimposed
on the earth and the stars
and it explains the fact
that the earth turns around
itself like a merry-go-round.
And the other three illustrations
are actually somewhat more
interesting, especially the
two on the right-hand side.
So on the top one in Herman and
Nina Schneider's You Among the Stars
illustrated the Symeon Shimin
the page before explains actually
that the earth is like
going to the dentist,
which is a painful thing isn't it.
But you go to the dentist and
you sit in the dentist's chair
and you take your brother
and your brother spins you
around in the dentist's chair right.
So that is the earth
spinning around itself.
And now imagine if you're
putting this dentist's chair
on a merry-go-round.
So the center of the
merry-go-round is the sun,
the one which is all the horses turn
and then your brother turning you
in the dentist's chair is the
earth turning around itself.
And at the bottom right you have
Julius Schwartz's The Earth is Your
Spaceship from 1963.
So this is also interesting
because it is an early mention
of the earth being a spaceship
where they put the merry-go-round
on a truck and the truck
drives in a circle.
Okay, so here the earth is the
merry-go-round and the truck driving
in the circle is the path
it takes around the sun.
And last one of these on
the bottom left Gerald Ames
and Rose Wyler again, they wrote
a lot of books about the earth.
This is called Planet Earth
this book and illustrated
by Cornelius DeWitt and there you
have the earth turning around itself
with people standing on it.
So the earth is the green planet and
on top of it is the merry-go-round.
So rather than superimposing
it they attached it at the top
so you can see both the planet
turning, you can explain
that down is always towards
the center of the earth,
and that the earth is turning
around itself like a merry-go-round.
So if you remember back to what
you thought about the earth
and how you might explain
the earth as a planet
to a child did you
find any parallels,
did you find any differences,
did you think of a ball,
did you think of a merry-go-round,
did you think of a
dentist's chair maybe?
If you have any thoughts
you want to share
about that I would be very happy
to hear them maybe after the Q&A.
And so far the only
thing that remains for me
to say is oops, thank you.
There we go and that have now
arrived on the planet earth
and you see all my sources where
the illustrations came from.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And if you have questions
feel free to ask them.
Is there?
>> Jason Steinhauer: We have
about five minutes of tape left,
so it will be five minutes of Q&A
and then [inaudible] will
stick around and [inaudible].
>> Sibylle Machat: Sure.
>> You mentioned [inaudible] you
mentioned about [inaudible] talk
about how the American [inaudible].
>> Sibylle Machat: Okay, I
can say something about this,
but this might not
be my final answer.
So something I want to actually do
for my project I'm learning Russian
right now and I want to go to Moscow
to look at the children's
book archive and after
that I will have a
much bigger answer.
But from what I've seen so far
is the art style is of course,
very different, clouds show
up around the same time.
So we have a strange parallel in
the presence and absence of clouds,
but again we have a focus
that is far less on Russia
which is something I found
really, really interesting.
And at first I thought is Russia
maybe too big to fit on the earth,
but it's not true if you look
at the globe you can
actually see all of Russia.
But they frequently focus on
either the North Pole so looking
at the earth kind of from above,
but it tilted a little more
towards Russia than straight north.
Or they show the western
part and Europe,
Europe and then the western part of
Russia, that's what I found so far.
The text -- I have
a friend in Germany
who helped me translate some
things because he's a translator
and the text I haven't
really looked at
yet because my Russian
isn't good enough yet.
But I hope to come back to you
with an answer because I thought
if I'm looking at American books
wouldn't it be super interesting
to look at both space
powers and do that.
And I've looked at
some German books,
I've looked at some British books,
but if I look at those then you can
just say aren't you being arbitrary
why aren't you looking
at French books
and Spanish books and Chinese books.
So I said no, the two space
powers is what I really want
to write about.
So my project has kind of grown.
>> It appeared that there were
suddenly an abundance of books
in the 1930's, what
would account for that?
>> Sibylle Machat: I think from what
I found it's really only the 40's.
I showed you the examples
I found in the 30's,
but these are actually some
of the only books I found
in the 30's whereas in the 40's
and 50's I really had to choose.
And I think the sort of what
accounts for it is for the lack
of books on the one
hand is that there are
so many books about airplanes.
So if you want to write books for --
adventure books for boys
they're all about aviation.
I've looked at so many aviation
books which then have modern planes,
the new planes that will be
invented, adventures in planes,
going to the North Pole in
planes, going here in planes,
famous people who flew planes.
Really there are so many
of those, but then I think
with the development of technology
and with the first
rockets being invented
by the Germans during the second
world war and these then coming
to the states that's sort
of when people realized
it might become realistic
that we can go into space.
And that's when you really see
these books taking off and certainly
after 1952, 53, 54, that's where
most of my books really start.
Which is actually kind of
late for me, I want to do ones
from before we have
photographs of the earth,
before we have the pictures of the
clouds, when there aren't that many.
It's after we have the first
photographs and the V2s go
into space and take these
pictures and people start writing
about [inaudible] and
Huntsville and all of that
and then Cape Canaveral
slash Cape Kennedy later,
that's when the books really,
really start appearing.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Sibylle Machat: That is
a very, very good question.
Of the picture books that I have
found here there hasn't been any
earth, but negative evidence
is not complete evidence.
So to be able to say I
really can't find any earth
in the British children's books I
need to go to the British library
and look at the early
British children's books.
And then all I can say
is that in the books
that are here there is
no picture of the earth,
but on the one hand I focused
on American children's books
so I didn't spend a lot of time
at the British children's book.
I more went this is kind of
interesting I wonder what's in them
as I found out when
the first pictures
of the earth start appearing.
And yeah, as I said, it's
just me saying that there's
at least one swan in England,
which is white on one side rather
than saying all swans in
England are white okay.
>> Jason Steinhauer: I think
we'll stop there [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
So I think Sibylle will stick
around for a few more minutes she
has a few books that she has brought
in for people to look at and she
can answer a few more questions.
The Kluge Center is on break with
our programming until October,
at which point we have a
number of lectures coming up.
So please do sign our
list on the way out
and thank you again for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.